hi everybody and welcome my name is Alex
Chisholm and I'm the product manager for
puzzer cloud here at posit
in this first installment of positive
Cloud Essentials we're going to cover
everything you need to know about
getting started with a free account in
just a few clicks
posit cloud is an online platform where
you can do and share data science in
your favorite coding and languages all
from the comfort of your web browser
in essence puzzlecloud makes it easy for
you to manage a variety of data projects
in siled reproducible environments that
contain your code your data and your
results all of which can be shared
a space and posit Cloud serves as the
building block for the tool
you can create our projects in the
rstudio IDE or work natively with python
and Jupiter
you can publish data applications and
documents from cloud or from an external
environment such as rstudio desktop or
vs code
you can also securely store database
connections to power your projects and
outputs using a set of 16 included
professional drivers
finally you can invite members to your
space to collaborate on work or to
Simply showcase your results
all the while keeping your eye on usage
analytics for specific pieces of content
posit cloud is a freemium tool this
means that you're able to create a free
account and gain access to all of its
functionality
if you happen to run into limitations in
terms of compute power or number of
published outputs feel free to explore
the affordable and flexible paid plans
on today's demo we're going to create a
free account set up our first space and
then do some real work
let's get started by going to
posit.cloud
so when you get to posit.cloud you're
going to find a variety of options and
information about the tool
the first thing you want to do is set up
an account you can click on get started
to start the process
you'll see a variety of plans today
we're just going to start with a free
plan
when you click sign up
you're going to be able to either put in
an email and password along with your
first and last name or you can sign up
directly from something like Gmail with
Google or GitHub I'm going to go ahead
and use Google
so I have an account already set up on
Gmail for this demo I'm going to click
it now we've now created my posit cloud
account
it's going to redirect me into the tool
for us to begin doing work
when you first log in you're going to be
brought to an area called your workspace
you might want to think about this area
like a playground
you can create new projects and
experiment with Publications
but for this demo we're going to create
a more functional space called a new
space by clicking this button
and when I do this why don't we go ahead
and name it we'll name it biostats
so if I create this new space you can
see that I brought into something that
looks relatively similar to that first
area we went into but there are more
tabs and there is more functionality in
here that we're going to use throughout
the demo
the first thing I want to do is create a
data connection
you don't have to do it this way but
since we're going to use this for our
example might as well start there
so if you go across the top of the pane
and click on data you can see that there
are no current data connections so I can
go ahead and add one
by clicking on driver you can see all of
the different types of database
connections that we can save I'm going
to use postgres
and I'll go ahead and name this
connection
RNA Central
for this example we're going to use a
public data set or database I should say
which you can find more information on
rnacentral.org including the credentials
to to log in and start making queries
against it
so for now I'm just going to paste in
all the information I need here
first I have my server
I got my port number
going to bring in the database name
itself and then finally my username and
password
you'll notice when you've when I pasted
in the password here that we don't
actually see what it is
we're also going to be able to save this
as an encrypted variable which will
become an environment variable when we
open up our studio in a few moments
so let's go ahead and hit OK
I now have my database connection store
I'm going to go back to content and
we'll create our first project
clicking this blue button I can create
either in our studio project or a
Jupiter project I can also create one
going straight to a GitHub repo but for
now we're going to go ahead and create a
new rstudio project
so this should take around 20 seconds to
deploy and during this time I might as
well go ahead and rename my project and
we'll just call this RNA analysis
so we're up and running we have a fully
functioning rstudio IDE session here
and we have to decide what do we want to
do next
and typically one of the first things
you're doing in data analysis right is
connecting to some kind of data source
so we can go and retrieve that
connection we made earlier and if I go
in here to the upper right hand panel
and click on connections click new
connection you'll see what we saved
earlier is already here
so I'm going to click this
and we'll see that our studio is going
to give us the ability to create some
credentials to make the connection first
I'll test it
so testing is going to go out it's going
to install the packages that I need for
this specific type of postgres database
connection and you can also see that one
it is a success two you can see in the
script that's going to be made for our
connection we're using a environmental
variable to mask the the password so we
don't need to keep the password of this
database in the script that we use
why don't I go ahead and load this into
new R script
and we can load
the the package that we need
odbc and also DBI
I can go ahead and make my connection
once that connection is made you'll see
again in the connections tab all of the
different tables and schemas available
to us from this connection
we want to do a little bit more let's
start querying this
and one good package to do that is DB
plier
maybe I'll save this script as connect
I don't yet have DB plier installed so
let's go ahead and do that
DB plier is going to allow us to use
relatively straightforward commands to
go out to the database run some queries
and bring back data
along with that installation we get B
plier which will help with some of the
some of the code to get this
so let me also load that Library
and now I'm just going to bring in as an
example
some code that says let's make a new
variable called results
I'm going to go out to this table within
the database
I happen to know that it is in the table
called RNA
I only want to get the top 100 rows but
I do want to bring this back to me so I
can look at what's in there
so if I run this
if I load the libraries
and then run this
you can see now we've stored a variable
name results if I click on the
environment tab I'll be able to see
results
clicking on it shows me the 100 records
and the type of variables that we have
in here
so that's great we were able to go out
from our database connection grab some
real data and now we can do something
with it
I also want to add on the bottom here
just a database disconnect if I were to
run that script later on so we can kill
our connection to that database
now what if I wanted to take the
information that we saw and put it into
an interactive report
well I can go ahead in the same session
and create a new shiny web app
and this is going to ask me to install
packages related to shiny which is
relatively quick
and we're going to take the base example
and we're going to swap in this real
database connection to have a a new
example that we can use to test the
functionality of both creating these
interactive applications and then
publishing it to Cloud
so maybe we call the application RNA
I'm now in a shiny script and I can do a
few things
first I just want to bring this data or
bring this this code sequence over to my
app
I'm just going to paste it at the top
maybe clean it up a little bit remove
the libraries next to each other I still
want to go out to and get a connection
to this database
now that I'm going to move into the
actual application maybe I don't want
just 100 records maybe I want 2 000
records
and I'll leave this this disconnect here
as well so that when the application
goes out grabs the data it also closes a
connection
so then we want to work this new data
into this example and we'll go through
and just change a few things from this
stock example that is in here maybe we
call this RNA analysis
and leave all of this
one important thing I'm going to do is
change my my data I no longer want to
take
the the sample data I want to bring in
results and I want that length variable
and then finally we can just do a few
things to change how it looks maybe I
get rid of the X label x axis label
completely and then I change the overall
title to
RNA length
I think we've done everything that we
need we need I can also probably
simplify my my call to the database I
know I only need that length variable
maybe I'll bring you the ID and length
all right so now we have what I think is
an updated app based upon that data
connection that we made
why don't we go ahead and preview this
and let's try to get this to show up in
the viewer pane so that we all can see
it here
I'm going to run my app
yep and it worked we can see that we
still have this slider to control uh the
the number of bins within our histogram
but from the data that we're pulling in
once again live from this database we
can see that we kind of have a split
distribution with a lot of records that
are up in that 1500 range and then
several that are down 500 and below
so that's great right we've gone through
we've made a shiny app we've brought in
real data to it what is fantastic about
positive cloud is you can also now
publish this app specifically to your
space
either to go straight there next time
when you want to see the maybe updated
results or if you want to share it with
other people without having to let them
into your project
so why don't I I'm gonna I'm gonna
cancel this and now we're going to move
over to publishing
this is the push button publisher within
the rstudo IDE if I click on this
it's going to ask me again to install
some packages these packages are going
to assist with the publishing process
and once this is ready it's going to ask
me for a few different things
the first thing it's going to ask which
are the files you want from this folder
to upload right now I only have this
application.r file so that's the only
one I'm going to bring up
is going to ask me where am I going to
try to publish this to and what is
fantastic is just by setting up this new
positive cloud account we have already
matched your your tokens and your
secrets and all those credentials that
you need to publish
automatically so when you press publish
now it will put all of this this
interactive application into your own
space
so I'll click this
given the size of this and the amount of
files that we're putting up this will
probably take a couple of minutes so let
me show you a few other things you might
have noticed the the ram indication at
the top so it's telling us how much of
our available memory we're using right
now we're at about 50 percent
if I click on the gear we can see that
we can add in analysis or we can add in
a description that'll show up later
so analysis of RNA beta maybe is what we
want to put
I click access I can see that only I can
see this right now but maybe we want
everybody to see this so I'm going to
change it to everybody in biostats
and then finally if you wanted to change
the Ram or the compute or the background
execution time you can do that from
these toggles
this is a free account so if you try to
go over one gigabyte of RAM for instance
it would tell you you can't do that and
you would have to upgrade into a paid
plan to get up to to 16 and very soon 32
gigabytes of memory
and now I think this is ready to launch
and what will happen it'll try to put it
up in a new tab it blocks it the browser
blocks it initially but if you hit try
again
so this pops up in a new tab we have our
interactive application going out
grabbing the data from the database and
allowing the user to then change the
number of bins associated with the
histogram for the length variable
so this is pretty cool
if I click back on biostats into my
space I'm going to see a few things
I now have two pieces of content
I have my shiny application and I have
the RNA analysis project
when we were going through the project
we already decided to make the the
project be available for all space
members
you can see that this project has
created one output which is this RNA app
but you can see that the app itself is
set to private right now
if I go to the dot dot dot here
in settings I can change the access
rights for the application itself
so I can change it from you to everybody
in biostats
now of course the only person in
biostats at the moment is me the creator
of the space
but if I go to members I can start
managing who has access and rights to
come into my space interact with my
projects and view my outputs there are a
few ways that we can do this I could do
an invitation requirement where I click
on ADD member and I would put in your
email address you would get an email
inviting you to the space you'd have to
sign up for posit Cloud but then you can
become a member within this space
or another common way is through sharing
a link and if you share a link you can
also select the role of the person who
is going to be invited in and change the
permissions associated with what their
status would be again in this biostats
space
just for an example I'm going to copy
the sharing link and quickly go off
screen to another account that I have
I'm going to get the invitation I'm
going to accept the invitation
and now that I've done that I'm going to
be able to refresh my page here
and you can see in addition to the demo
user what we started with I've now
brought in a contributor named Alex
Chisholm who has a certain set set of
Rights
and going back to content because I've
made these two pieces of content
available to everybody who's a space
member
now Alex Chisholm on his account will be
able to see these two pieces of content
open up my project save it as a new one
for himself or interact directly with my
application and start playing with that
interactive dashboard that we made
the final bit that I want to show you
here and another benefit deposit cloud
is when you have a lot of people in a
space and you have a lot of content that
could be interacted with it's nice to
know who is finding value in what
so if you click on the usage tab you're
going to find a set of usage analytics
for the specific space that you happen
to be in
you can set it to calendar month or your
billing month or the usage period if you
happen to be on a paid plan we just
started this space so you want to expect
a lot of activity but if you go in here
you can see that both the demo user and
Alex Chisholm the other member are
accounted for
the person we invited hasn't interacted
with anything yet so they don't have any
compute hours associated with the assets
but if I click on demo user you're going
to be able to find out just exactly what
pieces of content that this person has
been engaging with and you can see most
of the compute time has been associated
with the project for RNA analysis more
so than the output itself
I know we covered a lot of information
in this cert in this short tour but I
think it touched on all of those major
parts those pillars those building
blocks of positive Cloud that we started
with today
we were able to create a new project
publish an output
both of which were based on a live data
connection
we showed a little bit about member
management within your space and then
looking at usage analytics to see what
people are up to so we've been able to
do a lot I hope you enjoyed that
demonstration of positive Cloud we
continue to innovate and add features
and functionality I encourage you to
visit posit.cloud to create a free
account today and reach out to us if you
have any questions and we're happy to
take some here as well during q a thanks
so much